Salut, aujourd'hui je suis avec
Monsieur Jonathan,
[Jo] Bonjour !
[Fab] Alias As2piK
[Fab] Qui, à la base,
si vous ne connaissez pas As2pik,
tu fais des vidéos de Gaming,
[Fab] tu fais beaucoup de stream,
[Jo] Exactement.
[Fab] beaucoup de Twitch, et
tu es toujours sur Youtube.
[Jo] Exact.
[Fab] Tu es un vieux de Youtube.
[Jo] Un très très vieux de Youtube.
[Fab] Un très très vieux de Youtube.
[Fab] Tu as commencé Youtube, je ne savais même pas qu'on faisait des vidéos sur Internet.
[Fab] Bref ! Aujourd'hui c'est
un nouveau Boost Brain,
je crois que ce n'est que le 3ème
de 2017...
J'en avais fait 2 ou 3 l'année dernière
là c'est le 3ème, euh...
tu es venu voir mon spectacle,
[Jo] Exactement.
[Fab] C'était cool, merci.
[Jo] Ah ben c'était cool, merci à toi.
[Fab] Parce qu'on est à Grenoble !
Si vous, vous voulez faire comme As2pik
la semaine prochaine je serais à Lyon,
la semaine d'après à Narbonne,
après je sais qu'il y a du Valence,
du Bordeaux, plein de trucs comme ça...
[Fab] C'est dans la description.
[Jo] Allez-y, c'est vachement bien.
[Jo] Vraiment.
[Fab - Chuchotant] Je dois payer, un petit peu,
sous la table.
[Rires]
[Jo] On a dit pas dans la vidéo...
[Fab] Pas dans la vidéo !!
[Fab] On coupe ça !!
[Musique Générique]
[Fab] Je me suis dit : je vais inviter
Jonathan à venir,
pour lui apprendre un maximum
de décimales de Pi,
peut-être 30. Tu vois ?
[Jo - ironique] Ce qui va me servir
tous les jours dans ma vie...
[Fab] Mais ça va te servir grave !
[Jo] Ah ça c'est sûr...
[Fab] Et, vous allez pouvoir le faire en même
temps que lui, c'est le but des Boost Brain,
et en même temps, vous allez voir que
même si j'utilise, moi, plein de techniques
précises pour la mémoire,
que vous pouvez retrouver sur
les playlists de mémoire,
on peut aussi en improviser, en fait.
Ne pas avoir forcément de technique
initiale, et en improviser pour retenir
une longue séquence de chiffres
Ça peut être un numéro de
téléphone qu'on vous donne à la volée,
ça peut être un code WiFi,
ça peut être un code de BitCoin
ce que tu veux en fait,
tu vois ?
[Jo] Ça marche avec les chiffres et les lettres ?
[Fab] Ouais.  Ouais, ouais.
[Jo] Donc ça peut quand même
être utile, effectivement.
[Fab] Ah ! Tu vois !
[Jo] Ça peut être utile.
[Fab] Alors on prend Pi
pour l'exemple quoi...
ça nous permet, en plus, de faire
une belle miniature putaclic...
avec un titre putaclic, tu vois ?
Mais c'est pour ça...
[Jo] Pi... Les 80 premières décimales
de Pi sur la miniature,
sur la miniature, je ne suis
pas sûr que ça marche très bien...
[Fab] Ah ouais ?
[Jo] Je t'apprendrai ce que c'est...
[Rires]
[Fab] C'est çà !
[Fab] Non, mais si, c'est vachement bien !
[Fab] C'est putaclic pour ceux qui aiment les maths...
[Jo] C'est vrai...
[Jo] Mais il n'y en a pas beaucoup...
[Fab] On va faire la première séquence
qu'en images animées.
[Fab] Imagine un car
et dans ce car il y a une main géante posée.
Et dans cette main géante,
il y a un œuf.
Qui prend l'ensemble de la main.
En haut de cet œuf, il y a
deux scies qui tournent
pour l'ouvrir, comme un œuf
à la coque.
Tu vas mettre ton doigt,
tu vas le tremper un peu dans l’œuf,
et tu vas te faire une tache dans le cou.
[Fab] Ça fait un cou-tache.
[Jo] D'accord, ok.
[Fab] Ok ?
[Jo] Ouaip !
[Fab] Jusqu'ici tout va bien ?
[Jo] Jusque là tout va bien.
[Fab] Est-ce que tu peux me faire
un récap de toute cette imagerie ?
[Jo] Il y a un car qui arrive,
[Fab] Ouais.
[Jo] Dans ce car il y a une main qui tient un œuf,
[Fab] Ouais
[Jo] Cet œuf... en haut de cet œuf
il y a 2 scies qui coupent le sommet,
[Fab] Ouais.
[Jo] et une fois que le sommet est coupé,
je trempe mon doigt et je me fais un cou-tache.
[Fab] Pour moi, un car c'est un 4
[Jo] un 4, ouais
[Fab] Une main, ça a 5 doigts,
donc ça vaut 5.
[Fab] Un œuf c'est un 9,
un 2 c'est un 2,
une scie, c'est un six...
et puis cou-tache,
ça c'est juste pour avoir des consonnes en tête.
Si j'enlève toutes les voyelles
de cou-tache,
ça fait C, T, C, H.
C de cinq... T de trois...
[Jo] Ok.
[Fab]C de cinq, H de huit.
[Jo] Ouais, d'accord.
Ok, ok, ok.
[Fab] Tu vois. Cou-Tache et
j'ai enlevé toutes les voyelles.
[Jo] Ouais, ok.
[Fab] C'est un autre principe pour retenir.
[Fab]Le suivant, c'est toi
qui va me proposer des choses.
[Jo] Ok.
[Fab] Euh... 89, ça t'inspire quoi ?
[Jo] Mon année de naissance.
[Fab] Oh, super.
[Jo] 79 ? Euh... 7, DocSeven
[Fab] Ouais
[Jo] Et 9, euh... carré de 3.
[Fab] Vous n'avez pas de chance
parce qu'il a une logique un peu comme la mienne,
c'est à dire une logique très personnelle
au niveau des chiffres,
[Jo] Mathématique peut-être...
[Fab] Ouais.
[Jo] Ouais.
[Fab] Parce que, si je te dis 8, 4, 6,
est-ce que tu trouverais
une logique à 8, 4, 6 ?
[Jo] 8, 4, 6... Euh....
[Fab] Parce que moi je me dis hu...
[Jo] Une séquence mathématique, quoi,
[Jo] 8 si tu le divises par 2, ça fait 4,
[Fab] Plus 2, ça fait 6.
[Jo] Plus 2 ça fait 6, ouais.
[Fab] Ouais, exactement.
[Jo] Puisque plus la moitié ça fait 6, ouais
[Fab] Ouais.
[Fab] Je me suis dit ça aussi, ouais,
8 divisé par 2 plus 2.
[Jo] Ouais.
[Fab] 8, 4, 6.
[Fab] Ok.
[Fab] Alors, dans ces cas là, on va
essayer de créer un truc assez rapidement,
il y a ton année de naissance
au départ,
[Jo] Ouais.
[Fab] Donc, DocSeven qui t'offre un oeuf carré
pour ton anniversaire...
après, il y avait une petite logique progressive
[Fab] C'est à dire, après, il y avait 2, 3 qui se suivent
[Jo] 2, 3
[Fab] Et après on était sur le 8, 4, 6.
[Fab] 8 divisé par 2, plus 2.
[Jo] Ouais.
[Fab] Est-ce que ça, tu crois que
tu pourrais le retenir de manière brute
ou il faudrait un petit truc pour l'enfoncer ?
[Jo] Le 2, 3 ça va aller.
Pour la séquence de suite... 8, 4, 6...
[Fab] Je pense qu'avec le 8, tout
te reviendrait en fait.
Si on te colle une image de 8 par exemple,
le reste reviendrait.
[Jo] Ouais, le 8 divisé par 2, plus 2.
Oauis, ça je vais m'en souvenir.
[Fab] Je pense qu'on peut caler
le symbole de l'infini quelque part...
[Jo] Euh... 2, 3... jusqu'à l'infini.
Ouais, ça peut se faire, ouais.
[Fab] Ta logique.
[Jo] Deuxième séquence par image, ok...
[Jo] Alors... pour mon anniversaire,
DocSeven
m'offre... un oeuf
[Fab] Ouais.
[Jo] Cet oeuf... est carré.
[Fab] Exact.
[Fab] Ouais, ouais.
[Jo] 2, 3 jusqu'à l'infini, 8, 4, 6
[Fab] Ça marche.
[Jo] On peut se tenter un dernier
[Fab] Comme ça, ça fera 31
[Jo] Ok                         Ouais
[Fab]    Ça Marche ?
[Fab] Allez, on essaie ça
[Fab] Euh... j'essaye de voir ce qui
serait bon pour toi...
[Jo] 64 plus, ouais.
[Fab] Alors, 64 c'e...
[Jo] Ma première console Nintendo, ouais.
[Fab] D'accord, ok.
Alors, on en a deux.
Deux consoles.
[Fab] Parce que c'est 2, 6, 4.
[Jo] Ok.
[Jo] 33, deux 3 qui se suivent,
ça devrait aller.
[Fab] Donc tu peux imaginer le 3...
Tu mets un 3 sur chaque console, si tu veux.
[Jo] Ah ouais ! Ok.
[Fab] Le fait de se l'imaginer
une fois, ça va t'aider...
[Jo] Avec 3 manettes chacune, donc...
[Fab] Ouais, voilà ! 3 manettes...
[Jo] Ouais, ok.
[Fab] Donc tu as 2 Nintendo 64
[Fab & Jo] avec 3 manettes chacune.
[Jo] Une boule de billard
écoute, là sur le 8, on peut
partir sur la boule de billard.
[Fab] Ouais. Sur une boule
de billard...
[Jo] Boule de 8.
[Fab] Tu imagines ta boule de billard,
mais GEANTE,
qui arrive et qui dégomme
complètement une des deux euh...
[Jo] Ouais. Et du coup je me retrouve
avec 32   64
[Fab] Tu te retrouves avec la motié des consoles.
[Jo] Ouais, Ok.
[Fab] Et on revient sur du 79
mais tu n'avais rien d'accroché
au départ
on avait imaginé Doc
qui t'offre un oeuf.
[Jo] Doc et son œuf, si on continue
l'histoire c'est Doc et son œuf...
[Fab] On peut la récupérer.  Ouais.
[Jo] du coup, ouais.
[Fab] Je pense que tu peux juste imaginer
voilà, Doc et son œuf
qui apparaît
ben, par exemple, qui euh...
c'est lui qui va stopper
la boule de billard de l'autre côté.
[Fab] qui va l'arrêter.
[Jo] Ok.
[Fab] Tu vois ? Donc, dans la mécanique,
tu as les 2 consoles Nintendo 64
[Jo] La boule de billard arrive
[Fab & Jo] Avec les 3 manettes !
[Fab & Jo] La boule de billard arrive
[Fab] elle dégomme...
[Jo] les Nintendo 64
[Jo] Donc j'ai 32
[Fab] Et c'est Doc qui, à l'autre bout
[Jo] Doc
[Fab] tu sais, genre un changement de plan
tu vois. C'est lui qui récupère la...
[Jo] Avec son œuf dans la main.
[Fab] Avec son œuf, exactement.
[Jo] Ouais. Ok.
[Fab] Ok ?
[Fab] Bon alors : c'est parti !
[Jo] Juste les images maintenant ?
[Jo] ou les chiffres ?
[Fab - en simultané] Les chiffres !
[Fab] Pi commence par 3 virgule...
[Jo] 1... 4... 1... 5... 9... 2... 6...
5... 3... 5... 8...
[Fab] Exact.
[Jo] Ensuite...
8... 9...
7... 9...
2... 3...
Non ! non, non, non, non ,non
7... 9...
Euh... 7, 9, 3 !
[Fab] Oui.
[Jo] 2, 3, 8
Euh....
4, 6
[Fab] Exact.
[Jo] 6, 4
2, 6, 4 !!
2, 6, 4, 3, 3... 8... 7, 9 ?
Non, j'ai oublié un truc ?
Ah non !  Euh...
8... 3, 2, 7, 9.
[Fab] Ouiiii !!!!
[Fab] Tu viens de me dire trente...
et un chiffres de Pi
[Jo] De Pi.
[Jo] Ah c'est...
[Fab] Il t'aura fallu, euh...
je pense, en temps d'apprentissage pur,
une dizaine de minutes.
Tu vois ?
[Jo] Et ça fait 15 ans que je connais
les 5 premiers
14, 15, 9
[Jo] Et que je n'ai pas réussi à me souvenir de la suite.
[Fab] Tu vois...
[Jo] Chapeau ! Chapeau.
[Fab] Et tu vois... Le truc intéressant
au final, euh...
que Jonathan, qui vous
représente en fait,
là à réussit à faire, c'est que,
on peut vraiment retenir n'importe quelle séquence
en fait, si on y trouve un jeu de mémoire.
Sans chercher une technique
particulière, précise et organisée,
[Jo] Juste une histoire en fait.
[Fab] Voilà.
[Fab] Mais des choses qui
vous parlent à vous.
Le meilleur moyen de ne pas s'en
souvenir c'est d'essayer de l'apprendre par cœur.
Et le meilleur moyen de s'en souvenir
c'est de vous faire confiance
dans l'imaginaire
et d'essayer de faire quelque chose
de bizarre pour les autres
mais, personnellement,
qui va fonctionner.
Il suffit, euh... là une séquence
comme ça, si tu te la répètes tous les jours
pendant une semaine, mais
une fois dans la journée,
elle va tenir.
Et puis après,
une fois par semaine.
Et puis voilà,
et puis ça va rester.
[Jo] Au bout d'un moment ça va rester, ça va...
[Fab] Exactement, ouais.
[Jo] Ok.
[Fab] Et à un moment donné,
tu serais même étonné,
c'est que euh...
tu ne vas même plus repasser
par les images,
les chiffres vont te venir
et tu sais, en fait.
[Jo] Ouais à force ça va...          ouais, bien sûr.
[Fab] Tu te fais confiance.
[Fab] Tu vois ?
[Jo] Ouais.
Mais au fond de toi,  dans tes synapses,
dans tes neurones
c'est toujours relié à ce système d'images,
mais tu n'as même plus besoin de passer par là.
c'est assez rigolo quoi,
tu vois ?
[Fab] Merci mec !
[Jo] Ben merci à toi.
[Fab] Merci beaucoup de t'être prêté à l'exercice.
[Jo] Super.
[Fab] J'espère que ça va vous motiver
à essayer de faire ça,
et que ça vous aidera à retenir
les mots de passe WiFi ou je ne sais quoi...
Si vous ne connaissez pas la chaîne
de Jonathan, je vous mets le lien juste ici
il est entre nous deux.
Ça, c'est pour s'abonner
à ma chaîne à moi, c'est juste là.
Vous pouvez liker la vidéo,
si vous le souhaitez.
Et à très bientôt !
[Fab] Ciao.
[Jo] Ciao !
[Musique générique de fin]